puis j'ai remarqué que les touristes qui
visitent le louvre ont l'habitude de
plus en plus de venir pique [ __ ] soit
dans les jardins qui sont dans la cour
intérieure soit sur les bancs qui sont
le long des galeries et même dans les
jardins du carrousel or dans ces dans
ces lieux on ne trouve pas de corbeil ce
qui fait que les détritus s'accumulent
et veulent avec le vent ou ceux viennent
s'accumuler contre les galeries contre
les monuments surtout en ce moment avec
les jeux de munich beaucoup de touristes
transitent par paris est certainement
ces gens là doivent avoir une piètre
opinion de des français et des parisiens
en particulier à votre avis quelles
seraient les remèdes à apporter à cet
état de choses je pense que très simple
de mettre du corbeil et bien les places
et
de veiller à ce que des gens ils mettent
leurs déchets et surtout d'assurer un
service enlèvement pour ne pas les
papiers vols de tous les côtés et même
se livrent les fenêtres du ministre des
finances ça dépend ça se répare
excessive on sait avec eux une douzaine
de corbeil mis en place et on en verra à
la fin
monsieur le coeur à raison de s'indigner
devant le spectacle déplorable qui
s'offrent aux visiteurs de l'un des
trois monuments les plus fréquentés de
france
ces images d'immondices et de papiers
gras abandonnés à eux mêmes se passe de
commentaires
dans ces lieux le pique nique est bel
est bien autorisé ces touristes
laisserait volontiers leurs déchets dans
des corbeilles si elle existait
et s'il suffit de poser 50 corbeil au
total pour tous les jardins du louvre et
du carrousel solution modeste n'est
pourtant efficace
l'administration des beaux-arts hésitera
tél il en va soyons en persuadés de la
réputation de la capitale